[Musik]
früher als alle anderen großbritannien
lässt den impfstoff von beyond eck zu
erste wagenladungen sind unterwegs
kommende woche soll das impfen losgehen
die frage nach dem warum
trier beweint die toten der amokfahrt
gegen den täter wird wegen mordes
ermittelt
ein kindheitstraum wird wahr nix
schumacher tritt in die fußstapfen
seines vaters und gibt nächste saison
sein formel 1 tippen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute nachrichten am mittwoch den
sport hat wie der norbert lehmann dabei
ein stück von mir
die deutsch amerikanischen partner bayon
tag und weise haben gestern erst die
zulassung ihres impfstoffs beantragt bei
der arzneimittelagentur der eu jetzt
brechen die briten vor und lassen den
impfstoff schon zu und kommen damit
allen anderen ländern zuvor von
fantastischen nachrichten spricht
premierminister boris johnson
kommende woche soll das impfen losgehen
insgesamt hat die britische regierung 40
millionen dosen bei den unternehmen
bestellt weil der wirkstoff zwei mal
verabreicht werden muss können damit 20
millionen menschen geimpft werden von
einem historischen moment ist die rede
doch es gibt auch viele fragen aus
london andreas stamm kleine flächen viel
hoffnung drin
in rekordzeit entwickelt und nun in
großbritannien in rekordzeit zugelassen
800.000 dosen des bei und texter
impfstoffs machen sich bald auf den weg
ins königreich fantastische nachrichten
zu der premier durch den schutz von
impfstoffen werden wir letztlich wieder
unser normales leben führen können und
der wirtschaft auf die beine helfen
bewohner und pfleger in altenheimen über
80-jährige medizinisches personal haben
priorität bis ende des jahres soll stoff
für millionen impfungen bereitstehen die
unabhängige zulassungsbehörde erklärt
das beschleunigte notfall verfahren
bedeutet keinesfalls weniger sicherheit
der zugelassene impfstoff erfüllt die
strengsten höchsten standards was
sicherheit wirksamkeit und qualität
angeht der schutz der bevölkerung war in
diesem verfahren immer das wichtigste
für uns das wichtigste für die regierung
schnelligkeit kein warten auf die
zulassung durch die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde ema bei und der
gründer janine lobt die britische
bürokratie die entscheidungsprozesse
sind entsprechend eben auch so
abgestimmt dass das schneller agiert
werden kann bei der ehemals ist so dass
die prozeduren weitere
maßnahmen und weitere weitere
interaktionen erfordern aber auch die
kollegen bei der ema muss man klipp und
klar sagen sind sehr aktiv wir sind in
fast jeden tag im kontakt der britische
sonderweg wäre auch für deutschland
möglich die bundesregierung allerdings
setzt auf das europäische
zulassungsverfahren bis ende dezember
das sei solidarisch und sicherer doch
egal wie und wo transport und verteilung
erfordern eine logistische
meisterleistung denn bei minus 70 grad
hält sich der impfstoff länger bei
kühlschranktemperatur nur einige tage
die britische zulassung ein meilenstein
in der korona bekämpfung aber nur einer
auf einem ansonsten noch langen weg auch
bei uns soll es ja bald mit dem impfen
losgehen in zdf heute live beantwortet
ein impfstoff forscher ihre fragen zum
thema um 19 30 auf zdf heute.de und in
unserer app österreich macht die grenzen
über weihnachten und neujahr praktisch
dicht das hat die regierung in wien
entschieden
hotels und gaststätten bleiben bis zum
siebten januar geschlossen
es gilt eine quarantäne pflicht für
einreisende aus gebieten mit mehr als
100 neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner
in 14 tagen das trifft neben deutschland
praktisch alle nachbarstaaten
österreichs in deutschland bleibt die
zahl der bewohner neuinfektion auf hohem
niveau und noch nie sind so viele
menschen an einem tag an oder mit 19
gestorben
das robert koch institut registrierte
17.000 270 neue fälle binnen eines tages
das sind 1363 weniger als vergangenen
mittwoch 487 todesfälle sind in 24
stunden dazu gekommen
die gesamtzahl der toten in verbindung
mit einer corona infektion liegt in
deutschland nun bei 17.000 123 zur
stunde tagen sie noch die
bundeskanzlerin minister präsidenten und
präsidentinnen beraten sich seit dem
mittag über themen wie ganztagsbetreuung
digitalisierung und den kampf gegen
rassismus
doch an einem thema kommen sie in diesen
zeiten sicher nicht vorbei gunther love
energy und das ist
thema corona sie beobachten die
konferenz für uns haben sie schon etwas
gehört märz läuft ja natürlich kommt man
bei dieser sitzung an coroner nicht
vorbei dazu sind sich bund und länder
aber auch die länder teilweise
untereinander in vielen punkten einfach
noch nicht einig genug da geht es um die
hotelübernachtungen für angehörige rund
um weihnachten
es geht um die lastenteilung die
finanzielle zwischen bund und ländern
und es geht um die frage wie soll es im
januar eigentlich weitergehen
da gibt es jetzt vorschläge dass man
sich vielleicht heute schon mal darauf
verständigt im januar dann
möglicherweise bis zum 10
januar maßnahmen zu verlängern das soll
heute noch keinen beschluss werden so
hat es die bundesregierung heute mittag
gesagt aber das könnte ein vorzeichen
dafür werden welche entscheidung dann in
den kommenden wochen noch vor
weihnachten gefällt wird als ausblick
auf den januar
und wir hören dass die sitzung lange
dauert es gibt eben auch bei den anderen
themen jenseits von krone relativ viel
diskussionsbedarf wir sind gespannt wie
das heute abend ausgeht ja und sie
bleiben dran für uns vielen dank stark
unterlag
auch der reisekonzern tui plant im
kommenden jahr weiter mit chor ohne
einschränkungen und sichert sich deshalb
zusätzliche staatshilfen
das unternehmen einigte sich mit dem
bund banken und privaten investoren auf
ein paket in höhe von insgesamt 1,8
milliarden euro
der weltgrösste reiseanbieter ist wegen
der korona pandemie in eine schwere
krise geraten
es ist bereits das dritte
milliarden-hilfsprogramm der bund könnte
sich über das paket direkt an dem
unternehmen beteiligen
zwei wichtige entscheidungen im
bundeskabinett heute zum einen will die
regierung mehr gegen rechtsextremismus
und rassismus tun und hat dafür einen 89
punkte plan beschlossen
so sollen politische bildung und
prävention gestärkt werden außerdem ist
eine studie zu alltagsrassismus geplant
und zwar in zivilgesellschaft wirtschaft
und öffentlichen institutionen der
andere beschluss eine umfassende reform
der kinder und jugendhilfe unter anderem
sollen kinder in pflegefamilien und
heimen besser geschützt werden
einen tag nach der amokfahrt in der
trierer innenstadt hat die
staatsanwaltschaft haftbefehl wegen
mordes gegen den fahrer des autos
erlassen
in der stadt herrscht tiefe trauer
hunderte kamen zu einer gedenkfeier für
die fünf toten
der bürgermeister sagte trier trauert
trier leidet trier resigniert aber nicht
julia schröter berichtet das wahrzeichen
von trier ist zur gedenkstätte geworden
hunderte versammeln sich am morgen an
der porta nigra um gemeinsam zu trauern
und zu begreifen was gestern passiert
ist
man kann es gar nicht erklären ich weiß
ich was in einem menschen vorgeht
im gedenken an die opfer werden kränze
niedergelegt fünf menschen sind getötet
worden darunter ein erst neun wochen
altes mädchen und sein vater 18 personen
sind zum teil schwer verletzt
das große leid das durch dieses attentat
verursacht wurde können wir nicht
ungeschehen machen aber wir können den
trauernden und den verletzten versichern
sie sind in ihrem schmerz nicht allein
die tödliche amokfahrt dauert nur etwa
vier minuten in der fußgängerzone fährt
ein mann in einem geländewagen mit hohem
tempo gezielt passanten um überrascht
sie nichts ahnen bei den
weihnachtseinkäufen kurz nach dem ersten
alarm kann er nahe der porta nigra
überwältigt werden
der fahrer ist ein 51 jähriger aus dem
raum trier
er war zur tatzeit betrunken und ist
möglicherweise psychisch krank warum er
die tat beging ist noch unklar
er hatte auch angaben gemacht die
angaben waren jedoch zum teil wechselnd
zum teil widersprüchlich ein
nachvollziehbares motiv für eine solche
tat lässt sich daraus bislang nicht
herleiten
am mittag wurde der tatverdächtige einem
richter vorgeführt der haftbefehl erließ
unter anderem wegen fünffachen mordes
die menschen in trier versuchen nun den
schock zu verarbeiten für die
angehörigen der opfer aber hat der
albtraum gerade erst begonnen
ausgrenzen beschimpfen bloßstellen in
den sozialen netzwerken ein immer
größeres problem für kinder und
jugendliche laut einer studie ist jeder
sechste schüler jede sechste schülerin
schon opfer von cybermobbing geworden
eine zunahme um 36 prozent in den
letzten drei jahren und die anfeindungen
lügen oder unterstellungen im netz
werden immer gezielter und härte ein
elementares problem ist dabei die
anonymität des internets andreas linke
über den kampf gegen cyber mobbing
ein spiel das mobbing simuliert der
schüler in der mitte ausgegrenzt von den
anderen prävention zu workshop in der 7
b der werkrealschule ostheim in
stuttgart schnell fühlen die teilnehmer
mit mobbing opfern
cyber mobbing betrifft fast zwei
millionen schülerinnen und schüler in
deutschland das problem wird gravierende
ebenso die folgen das zeigt die studie
ganz deutlich dass die abhängigkeit
beziehungsweise hinwenden zu tabletten
und alkohol gestiegen ist und auf der
anderen seite leider auch das thema
suizid ist weiter angewachsen
beleidigungen ausgrenzungen wüste
beschimpfungen das ungewollte verbreiten
von fotos im internet per mail in den
sozialen netzwerken es nimmt zu sagt die
studie und corona verschärft dass
unterricht und sozialkontakte finden
noch häufiger online statt mobilen
gegenmittel lernte klasse bei saskia
kari wir haben heute in dem workshop
auch erarbeitet das ist halt mitläufer
gibt also jugendliche gibt sie dann halt
mit mit einsteigen und eine betroffene
person noch weiter piesacken aber dass
es auch leute gibt die sich ganz
raushalten aus dem system und die müssen
wir irgendwo kriegen und müssen die
befähigen da tatsächlich weitere
schritte einzuleiten
mehr solcher präventionsangebote könnten
helfen und vielleicht ein strafgesetz
wie in österreich
so fordert es das bündnis gegen
cybermobbing wie wichtig es ist sich
schnell auch juristisch gegen das
cybermobbing zu wehren erzählen
betroffene in unserer zdf heute app
juristen geben tipps wie man sich in
einem solchen fall am besten verhält
der hongkonger demokratieaktivist joshua
muss wieder ins gefängnis für 13 einhalb
monate auch zwei seiner mitstreiter sind
verurteilt worden
die bundesregierung kritisiert die
strafen meinungs- und
versammlungsfreiheit müssten für die
hongkonger bevölkerung gewahrt bleiben
peking hatte im sommer ein umstrittenes
sicherheitsgesetz verabschiedet das
ermöglicht es behörden gegen alle
vorzugehen die nach ihrer auffassung die
nach
regionale sicherheit chinas bedrohen
stefanie schöne bauen berichtet in
diesem bus sitzen drei verurteilte
aktivisten verurteilt weil sie für
demokratie und freiheit protestierten
wir sind bei euch brüder und schwester
scheinen sie ihnen zu
es sind nur wenige die sich noch trauen
nur wenige die vor dem gericht in
hongkong stehen vielleicht werden auch
sie demnächst verurteilt weil sie gegen
die verurteilung protestierten
das gericht folgt dem willen der
kommunistischen partei chinas sie in
ping will dass die proteste und alle
kritischen stimmen für immer
verschwinden die hongkonger regierung
versucht die drei zu stoppen sie so
lange wie möglich weg zu sperren
m und joshua bowman etwas mehr als einer
woche standen sie gemeinsam vor der
presse ein letztes interview
weder gefängnis wahl behinderung oder
willkürherrschaft kann unseren protest
aufhalten
verurteilt wurden die drei aktivisten
weise im juni 2009 10 eine versammlung
vor
hongkongs polizeipräsidium organisiert
habe
bei diesem schauprozess war wohl von
vornherein klar die aktivisten sollen
ins gefängnis chinas botschaft an alle
kritiker peking vergisst nicht und
bestraft heart of your chance
twitter-account steht derzeit im
gefängnis seine freunde veröffentlichten
einen handgeschriebenen brief er
beschreibt dass er in einzelhaft sei das
licht brenne 24 stunden 15 minuten
hofgang am tag zurück nach deutschland
thema missbrauch in der katholischen
kirche
auch das bistum münster hatte eine
studie in auftrag gegeben
heute stellten die forscher innen erste
ergebnisse vor und sprechen von
kontroll- und leitungs versagen der
katholischen kirche bis jetzt ist von
rund 300 opfern und etwa 200
beschuldigten die rede und von einer
hohen dunkelziffer dort färber mit den
einzelheiten
als messdiener war er dem kaplan
ausgeliefert martin schmitz immer noch
keine zehn jahre alt als der missbrauch
begann hilflos und schutzlos in der
kirche mann gottes macht auch keine
fehler
also musste doch alles das was sich da
irgendwie falsch anfühlt was da
irgendwie falsch war musste das doch bei
mir liegen im bistum münster wurden 300
menschen missbraucht so die ersten
erkenntnisse der historiker die akten
seit 1945 untersuchten auch wenn taten
dem bistum bekannt wurden blieben
priester im dienst
diesen befund ergibt sich das ist ein
massives leitung kontrollversagen
insbesondere gegenüber mehrfachtätern
gegeben hat viel von dem was wir
beobachten können eine entscheidung und
praktiken in der führungsebene zielt
darauf die priesterweihe bis beschuldigt
mit bruders zu erhalten
von einer scham kultur ist nun die rede
von vertuschung und sprachlosigkeit der
kirche das problem liegt darin dass man
allzu lange das leiden der betroffenen
für gering erachtet hat als die als den
schutz der täter und diese opfer
orientierung wo die sprachfähigkeit
gewonnen zu haben da ist ein prozess der
seit 2010 hier begonnen hat und die zahl
der betroffenen im bistum münster könnte
noch steigen
bislang haben die wissenschaftler erst
ein drittel ihrer materialien
ausgewertet zum sport und der formel 1
und da gibt es bald wieder einen
schumacher bereits doch so schön wie der
vater so der sohn
30 jahre nach dem debüt von formel 1
legende michael schumacher wird mit
schumacher nächste saison in die höchste
rennserie aufsteigen und zwar im harz
team für den 21-jährigen die erfüllung
eines kindheitstraums als ferrari junior
durfte er in der formel 1 schon
schnuppern
nun ist er offiziell angekommen in der
königsklasse eine grandiose sache ich
dass mein traum
dass er jetzt in erfüllung geht ist ist
unglaublich das us-team hat das rennen
gemacht weit 2016 in der formel 1 kein
sieger team für anfänger aber eine
top-adresse auch wegen seiner engen
zusammenarbeit mit ferrari mit
schumacher stellt sich der neuen aufgabe
erstaunlich gelassen
ich glaube dass ich dadurch dass ich die
ganzen die ganzen jahre über jetzt so
viel druck hatten dass ich dass ich da
halt auch gut umgehen kann
acht jahre nach dem karriereende seines
berühmten vaters michael nun also wieder
ein schumacher in der formel 1 der
seinen großen namen alle ehre machen
möchte die deutschen fußball frauen
ließen gestern abend auch den er ihnen
keine chance achtes spiel achter sie
keine perfekte qualifikation für die em
2002 und 20 nach 20 minuten war das
deutsche team per elfmeter in führung
gegangen da erzielte tabea fast nur der
erstes länderspieltor zum hochverdienten
2 0 in dublin kurz vor der pause
elfmeter für irland katie mccabe gegen
torfrau ann kathrin berger die in ihrem
ersten länderspiel das erste gegentor
der deutschen in der em-qualifikation
nicht verhindern kann
kurz vor schluss erhöht was mit noch zum
31 besser kann es nicht gehen zur em
2022 in england für das team von
bundestrainerin martina voss-tecklenburg
fußball-champions-league gestern abend
die bayern schon vor dem 12 1 gegen
atlético im achtelfinale
bei gladbach dagegen wieder alles offen
nach der 2 3-niederlage gegen hinter
zwei tore von mailand star lukaku hier
das 3 2 1 danach gelingt player für die
borussia nur noch der anschluss
ja und heute abend spielen noch dortmund
und leipzig in der königsklasse ist ja
da kannst du dann morgen darüber
berichten
ja danke norbert wegen corona müssen wir
derzeit nicht nur auf weihnachtsmarkt
und theater verzichten auch der
zoobesuch ist nicht mehr möglich
aber nicht nur uns fehlen die tiere so
einigen tieren fehlen auch wir offenbar
um ihnen die langeweile zu vertreiben
wurden die pinguine des aquariums von
chicago dieser tage auf entdeckungs
reise geschickt den publikumslieblingen
fehlt ihr publikum also versucht man sie
anders zu amüsieren
der ausflug in den kinosaal des
aquariums genau die richtige abwechslung
um die neugierigen eisvögel bei laune zu
halten
schön haben sie doch eine ja eine nette
abwechslung gute laune können vielleicht
auch diese zahlen machen
die gewinnzahlen lauten 12 32 41 43 44
und die superzahl 1 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 55 7
typisches dezember wetter erwartet uns
morgen hier und da fällt etwas schnee
oder schneeregen bei werten um null grad
droht weiterhin glättet details gleich
von katja honnefer das war es von uns
claus kleber freut sich auf die im
heute-journal aber erst um 10
danke für ihr interesse wir wünschen
einen entspannten abend und hoffen dass
sie morgen wieder dabei sind
[Musik]
knaben meine damen und herren vorbei ist
es mit dem milden wetter heute gab es ja
noch viel sonnenschein hier zwischen dem
erzgebirge und der lübecker bucht für
viele war das aber auch ein nebliger ein
hochwertiger tag aber jetzt kommt dieses
wolkenband heran das bringt regen und
schnee mit und auch in dieser nacht
fällt schon ein bisschen schnee an den
alpen interessanter ist aber der regen
hier im nordwesten sonst bildet sich zum
teil nebel und im nordosten ist es klar
die temperaturen sinken meist auf null
bis minus 7 grad nur im westen ist es
ein bisschen milder
die höchsttemperaturen morgen pendeln um
den gefrierpunkt milder wird es am
oberrhein und zwischen dem niederrhein
und sylt da werden so vier bis sechs
grad erreicht und dieser regen der da
von westen heran kommt das ist gar nicht
viel aber wenn er auf den gefrorenen
boden fällt dann wird es spiegelglatt
und im sauerland kann auch mal ein
bisschen schnee dabei ist ein im osten
ist es etwas freundlicher
es kann allerdings vormittags hier auch
ab und zu leicht stocken genauso wie in
süddeutschland deutlich gefährlicher ist
ist aber morgen richtung westerwald
taunus eifel und hunsrück länder fällt
schneeregen da wird es gefährlich glatt
auf den straßen passen sie da also bitte
auf der wind dazu kommt aus
südwestlichen richtungen
und in den nächsten tagen geht es
winterlich weiter und am freitag droht
dazu auch noch sturm schöner